in previous videos we've already looked
at using area models to think about
multiplying expressions like multiplying
X plus 7 times X plus 3 in those videos
we saw that we could think about it as
finding the area of a rectangle where we
could break up the length of the
rectangle as part of the length has
length X and then the rest of it has
length 7 so this would be 7 here and
then the total length of this side would
be X plus 7 and then the total length of
this side would be X plus and then you
have 3 right over here and what area
models did is they helped us visualize
why we multiply the different terms or
how we multiply the different terms
because if we're looking for the entire
area the entire area is going to be X
plus 7 X plus 7 times X plus 3 times X
plus 3 and then of course we can break
that down into these sub rectangles this
rectangle and this is actually going to
be a square would have an area of x
squared this one over here will have an
area of 7 X 7 times X this one over here
will have an area of 3 X and then this
one over here will have an area of 3
times 7 or 21 and so we can figure out
that the ultimate product here is going
to be x squared plus 7 X plus 3 X plus
21 that's going to be the area of the
entire rectangle of course we could add
the 7 X to the 3 X to get to 10 X but
some of you might be wondering well this
is all nice when I have plus 7 and plus
3 I can think about positive lengths I
can think about positive areas but what
if it wasn't that way what if we were
dealing with negatives instead for
example if we now try to do the same
thing we could say all right this top
length right over here would be X minus
7 so let's just keep going with it and
let's call this length negative 7 up
here so it has a negative 7 lengths that
we're not the saw used to thinking about
lengths is negative let's just
with it and then the height right over
here it would be X minus three so we
could write it X therefore that part of
the height and for this part of the
height we could put a negative three so
let's see if we kept going with what we
did last time the area here would be x
squared the area here would be negative
seven times X so that would be negative
seven x this green area would be
negative three X and then this orange
area would be negative three times
negative seven which is positive
twenty-one and then we would say that
the entire product is x squared minus
seven X minus three X plus twenty-one
and we could of course add these two
together to get negative 10x but does
this make sense well one way to think
about it is that a negative area is an
area that you would take away from the
total area so if X happens to be a
positive number here then this pink area
would be negative and so we would take
it away from the hole and that's exactly
what is happening in this expression and
it's worth mentioning that even before
when this wasn't a negative seven when
it was a positive seven and this was a
positive 7x it's completely possible
that X is negative in which case you
would have had a negative area anyway
but to appreciate that this will all
work out even with negative numbers I'll
give an example if X were equal to ten
that will help us make sense of things
so if X were equal to ten we would get
an area model that looks like this we're
having ten minus seven so I'll put minus
seven right over here times ten minus
three
now you could figure out in your heads
what's that going to be 10 minus 7 is 3
10 minus 3 is 7 so this should all add
up to positive 21 let's make sure that's
actually occurring so this blue area is
going to be 10 times 10 which is 100
this pink area now is 10 times negative
7 so it's negative 70 so we're gonna
take it away from the total area this
green area is negative 3 times 10 so
that's negative 30 and then negative 3
times negative 7
this orange area is positive 21 does
that all work out so let's see if we
take this positive area 100 minus 70
minus 30 and then add 21 100 minus 70 is
going to be 30 minus 30 n is zero and
then you just have 21 left over which is
exactly what you would expect you could
actually move this pink area over and
subtract it from this blue area and then
you could take this green area and then
you could turn it vertical and then that
would subtract out the rest of the blue
area and then all you would have left is
this orange area so hopefully this helps
you appreciate that area models for
multiplying expressions also works if
the terms are negative
an also reminder when we just had X's
here they could have been negative to
begin with